آل جولسون قد سجل نغمة الجاز الجذابة منذ ما يقرب من مائة عام،
لكنها لا تزال تتناغم مع
حالتي المزاجية الحالية،
وأنا متحمس للخروج واستكشاف هذه
الولاية الذهبية التي لم أزرها إلا من قبل  شاهدته في
الأفلام أو على شاشة التلفزيون
وما هو أفضل مكان للبدء من هنا
في ملعب الجولف الذي يعود إلى العصر الذهبي والذي يقع في
وسط مدينة لوس أنجلوس. لقد
أتيت إلى نادي ويلشاير الريفي
في قلب مدينة لوس أنجلوس في وقت مبكر قليلاً
للتعرف على  الدورة وتاريخها الغني
[موسيقى]
مضيفي لهذا اليوم هو
رئيس النادي برادفورد هيوز، وهو يأخذ
استراحة من التحضير للدورة التدريبية
لحدث LPGA القادم، بطولة JM Eagle
ليُطلعني على المكان،
لذا فهذا هو نادينا ومدخل أعضائنا
تحتفل هذه المنطقة بنورما
ماكبث، وهي مصممة ملعب الجولف لدينا
[موسيقى]، وهي
لاعبة غولف بطلة لديها
قائمة رائعة من البطولات التي فازت على مستوى الولاية
باسمها. صمم نورمان ماكبث هذا الملعب
على ما كان في ذلك الوقت قطعة
أرض فارغة تقع فوق بحر من النفط.
أخبرنا قليلاً عن كيفية
ظهور هذا المكان في أصوله، حيث
تأسس النادي في عام 1919 هنا في لوس
أنجلوس وفي ذلك الوقت لم يكن هناك
أي شيء حقًا في المكان الذي يوجد فيه النادي
الآن، كل هذا كان عبارة عن زيت ديريكس
وعندما  انظر إلى صور
ملعب الجولف هذا من عام 1919، إنه نفس
ملعب الجولف الذي ستلعب فيه اليوم
وهذا متعة حقيقية خاصة في
مكان مثل لوس أنجلوس حيث
الشيء الجديد الحديث هو نوع من الشيء الذي
يمكننا القيام به أنا وبرادفورد  مع هذا العرض
والتحدث طوال اليوم عن تاريخ الدورة التدريبية،
لكنني لم أقطع كل هذا الطريق حتى
لا ألعب بشكل
جيد، أنت مستعد، أنا مستعد.
انظر إلى أن
بعض أعضاء ويلشير الأوائل
كان من بينهم هوارد هيوز الذي كان لديه
نظرة شاملة على أحدهم  من أكثر
الثقوب الخلابة في الدورة،
ولكن إذا لم تكن حذرًا، فإن المنظر من الشارع
الثامن عشر يمكن أن يكون كافيًا لإلهائك
عن جولتك بأكملها، لذا فإن هذا
صندوق شاي رائع جدًا يمكنني رؤية
علامة هوليوود على المرصد ووسط
المدينة أعني يا له من  الموقع أعتقد أن
هذا هو المكان الأكثر تميزًا في
ملعب الجولف بالنسبة لي، وفي بعض الأحيان يكون من الصعب أن
تضيع في ملعب الجولف عندما تكون هنا
وتقدر الجمال الموجود في
وسط مدينة كبيرة مثل لوس
أنجلوس، لذا فهذا مكان خاص
يبدو الانتهاء من الحفرة أمرًا صعبًا للغاية من
هنا على الرغم من أنه يتعين عليك بالفعل عبور
المياه إلى جزيرة خضراء بشكل أساسي
ثم العثور على طريق لضربتين، لذلك إذا كان
أي شخص يستطيع القيام بذلك،
فلا يمكنك التأكد من أنني أحب ثقتك في
قدرتي على لعب الجولف
بقية اليوم، أنا سعيد لأنني
لن أكذب بشكل مثالي،
سأنهي
[موسيقى]
لعبة أحسنت، شكرًا جزيلاً لك